this would be your last interview ever
dad's deathbed plea to the daughter he
lost how can I fix this I think for
Thomas Markle the only way to get any
message to his daughter is through
television Meghan markle's dad said to
hit the airwaves yet again she would
still be a waitress if it wasn't for Dad
sitting down with Australia's seven news
Spotlight in a sneak peek of the
interview Thomas appears frail this
would be your last interview ever the 78
year old who suffered a stroke last year
wonders if there's hope to reconcile
and
death to the daughter he lost how can I
fix this I'm finding out that you're not
coming to our wedding
through a tabloid of course it's
incredibly sad what happened she had a
father before this yeah the couple had a
lot to say about Thomas in their Netflix
docu-series who else Megan's estranged
half-sister Samantha I don't know your
middle name I don't know your birthday
you're telling these people that you
raised me and you've coined me Princess
pushy it was great fun being big sister
and she was delightful
she along with brother Thomas Markle Jr
joined their dad in the new interview
she would still be a waitress if it
wasn't for Dad her parents were
incredible I hadn't had her fall out
with her we didn't have a closeness to
be able to have that
and I wanted a sister we're not going to
go away this is going to change
everything the interview is set to air
Sunday how can I fix this and the timing
of this explosive sit down seems very
intentional airing less than a week
before the coronation ceremony for King
Charles on May 6th my first reaction is
relief that Harry is going to be at his
father's coronation yep the Duke of
Sussex is navigating his own strained
relationship with his family and while
he'll be in attendance on his dad's big
day Megan will not so I'm surprised that
Harry is going alone not so much when
you realize that it's his son Archie's
birthday the very same day so Megan is
in fact going to be staying home in
California to celebrate that birthday
which is perhaps quite convenient given
the tensions between the two families
right now they are destroying us I think
most people are optimistic that this
relationship will heal over time I just
don't believe that the coronation is
going to be the place for that to happen
it's just too big of an event it's too
public there's going to be too many
people and too much going on but
hopefully it can be the start of some
real long-term healing
[Music]